فنطرح اليوم مساله عمر البشريه فقبل ايام
ماتت عميده البشريه رهيبه فرنسيه عن عمر
يبلغ 118 عاما مع وفاتها زاد الحديث عن
عمار البشر والى اي مدى يمكن الانسان ان
يعمر والصوره باختصار العالم يشيخ الناس
تعيش اكثر وبات السن التقاعد ازمه على
امتداد العالم واليوم تشير تقارير سكانيه
الى انقلاب القنبله السكانيه في كثير من
الدول لدرجه ان دول كبرى مثل الصين صارت
تدعو سكانها الانجاب بعد سنوات من العزوف
عن ذلك الامم المتحده اعلنت في تقرير
الاخير له انه بحضور منتصف القرن الحالي
ستكون دول افريقيا الجنوبيه وحدها قادره
على منزل العالم بالشباب بينما ستعان
القارات الاخرى من زياده معدلات الاكبر
هذه الازمه اصبحت اليوم قنبله موقوته
ينعكس بشكل سلبي على موازنات الدول وسط
غياب الحلول الحقيقيه للاسماء كيف تواجه
دول العالم ازمه كبار السن الماليه نتعرف
على ذلك
محاولات عديده من الدول لاجل مواجهه ازمه
قله الموارد الماليه المخصصه لكبار السن
ورعايتهم ومنها في الهند لجات ولايه كراء
للهنديه لمنح الدوله سلطات جديده
للاستحواذ على الممتلكات التي يتركها
الاباء لاولادهم في حال تخلوا عن رعايتهم
لهم دول اخرى تعمل علامه سن العمل ما يجعل
كبار السن قوه عمليه لاطول فتره ممكنه كما
حدث في فرنسا التي رفعت سن التقاعد عامين
ليصبح عند الربيعه والستين الامر الذي
واجهه اضطرابات
فيما تحاول بعض الدول الاخرى التي تعاني
من شيخوخه كبيره ان تشجع اجره العمال
الشباب اليها من البلدان الفقيره رغم
المخاوف من التغيرات التي قد تطرح على هذه
المجتمعات جراء هذه الهجره
[موسيقى]
فقره الجنوب الاقتصادي تنظيم الينا في
ستوديو صحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد سمر
اهلا بك طيب سمر ما هي الاعداء الماليه
على الدول التي يكبر سكانها في العمر بس
اريد اربط بين الموضوع اللي تكلمته في
قبائل كلمتيني عن الاعباء
الماليه ونتكلم بنفس الوقت عن السعاده
الزوجيه اليوم راح تكلم شويه عن التقاعد
السنه التقاعد يمكن هربطها ببعض يمكن
الاشياء لها خصم السعاده الزوجيه هي
استقلاليه المراه ماديا والعمل تكون عندها
عملها الخاص
وتربيه الاولاد
تكون المراه عامله مستقله ماديا نعود الى
الاعباء الماليه بالنسبه لرفع
ارتفاع العمر او متوسطه العمر بالنسبه
اشخاص بالتاكيد هناك الدول تتحمل خصوصا
الدول الاوروبيه انه تتحمل اعباء اللي هي
صحه النظام الصحي وايضا نظام التقاعد
اليوم الصندوق التقاعد في امريكا همم
متخصص بالمعاشات مهدده بعجز بسنه 2025
بحيث هناك مقترحات لرفع سن التقاعد الى
الثلاثه وسبعين مو بس 64 مثل المظاهرات
اللي تصير بالفرنسي حتى يتمكنوننا شويه من
سد هذا العجوز يعني نفهم من هيك انه رفع
سن التقاعد هو الحل المثالي يعني على
الاخذ باعتبار ما يحدث في فرنسا اليوم همم
خلينا نقول يمكن هو همم حل منطقي لانه انت
لما حتى القانون التقاعد حطوه سنه 1935
كان وعدل عمر المراه في حينها 64 سنه
بالمتوسط
المراه والرجل كان 60 احنا نعيش اكثر منهم
شويه ههه همم
اربع ستين ستين فهسه العمر الامفرج صار
تقريبا
صارت 84 86 فمن المنطقه انك ترفعين سنه
تقاعد يعني بالتاكيد انت عندك بعد تقريبا
بالمتوسط اكثر من 10 سنوات بروداكتيفيتي
انتاجيه هذا الى جانب انه غير انه تخفين
الاعباء الماديه على الدوله انه طبعا بدنا
نرجع صحيه للشخص اللي منتج للشخص العامل
يعني بحسب دراسه اجريت في هارد بدله ثلاثه
الاف شخص كل سنه عمل وراء 65 سنه تقلل خطر
الموت بعشره بالمئه بغض النظر عن الحاله
الصحيه خصوصا لما يجي الموضوع على الامراض
المزمنه مثل الكانسر الامراض القلبيه فانت
كل سنه اتعمل اضافيه تقللين بعد ال 65 خطر
الاصابه بالموت بعشره بالمئه طب لكن يقال
يا سمر مثل ما له ايجابيات هذا الموضوع له
سلبيات شو الايجابيات والسلبيات لرفع
السنه الثقافه
بالتاكيد اليوم المشكله عندنا مثلا
اول همم الجيل الجديد مثلا يرفض العمل
لفترات طويله يرفض العمل وقت طويل يرفض
العمل كجاب فيريدج قاعد حتى قبل 60 اللي
احنا جيلنا شويه المليونيل يمكن شويه
بدايه ال همم 60 بس عندك التقاعد اذا كان
همم حصل همم طريقه انه العمل مانتش مو
مرهق جسديا مو مرهق نفسيا فطبعا الى
الايجابيات الصحيه اللي ذكرناها سابقا
ورفع الاعباء الماليه من على الدوله اذا
كان عمرها طبعا لا تاخذين همم
انا بدي ارتاح بتقاعد فكم لازم ادخر من
معاشي حتى اتقاعد حتى انا مصروفك بس هو
المفروض عشره الى 15% من راتبك اتسيفرين
ثانويه حتى تكونين يعني يقال مرتاحه وانت
قاعده به سن 60 يكون عندك تقريبا مليون
ونص دولار همم انتخارات
فهذه المليون ونص يقال انه بالاذرجت
السايبين 10 الى 15% من راتبك طبعا هو
يعتمد على الراتب كل شيء طويل عريضه
موجوده اون لاين بس بالمتوسط والذي يحدث
حاليا ان الناس اللي عندهم جوبز يعني
نتكلم كوظيفه مش هو صاحب عمله يصيدون بس
سبعه في المئه من راتبهم سنه